Welcome to another episode of What's a
Prof? Welcome, Walter. We're back in the
old setting, Martin. Yeah, well, at
least we have some of the
the backdrop that we where we were.
An African sunset, or was it an African
sunrise?
I think this was a sunset. It was a
sunset. Okay. Yeah, well.
You titled this one Absentee Landlord.
Yes.
Can we pray and then you
explain to us how you got to this?
All right, let's do that.
Our heavenly Father,
thank you so much for bringing us
together again. Thank you for every
blessing that you bestow upon us, and we
ask that you now also enlighten our
minds with the Holy Spirit, and we ask
this in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
Martin,
Satan accuses God
of being an absentee landlord.
And then we struggle along in life,
and we sometimes despair. Now, my wife
recently wrote a book.
Well, she's been writing it for a long,
long time.
And she's been thinking,
"Do I do this? Do I not do this? Do I do
this? Do I not do this?
Uh
what is the right thing to do?
Because sometimes you have experiences
where you where you report things, and
people might perceive it as turning your
weapons against the church."
Uh yes, correct.
And
that is the last thing that we would
want to do.
But to be an ostrich and put your head
in the sand is also not wise.
Because people will suddenly come into
situations that they never expect, and
they walk in the front door, and they
walk out the back door.
But uh
this is still God's church and God's
people.
And there are lessons to be learned. And
one doesn't give up, one continues. So,
she wrote the book
about our life story. Yes. Called
Dwelling in a in the Secret Place.
I thought it was quite a nice title.
And it's available now,
and people can download it for free.
Yes. Yeah, it's on our website. The
links will be in the description as
well.
We encourage you to read it. Yes.
Because like you just mentioned,
Not as a negative, but as a positive,
what is what is the outcome of all of
this? Because a lot of people
just want to
give up and go. Yes.
Never give up.
Never give up. Don't go. No. Outside is
not is part of Shaken Out. Correct. So,
just for those who might be interested
in this story,
and uh of course, you can't tell cannot
tell everything in a story like that.
Because some things,
as we put it there in the beginning, for
the sake of prudence,
the best or the worst stories are not
even included.
Because that would take another book.
But we'll leave that for heaven.
We can
we can
cry on each other's shoulders there, or
laugh about it, laugh about it.
to, because God every tear will be wiped
away. Yes, we'll laugh about it. That
won't be a problem anymore. Okay, so but
that links back in, because obviously in
your life, you haven't heard
Absentee Landlord, the accusation of
Satan towards God, only once.
No, I've heard it many, many times. And
it's it leaves room for thought.
Why does God operate like he operates?
What is that movie, Martin, where
Satan accuses God of being the absentee
landlord?
When you when you gave me this to work
through, and I saw that
title, it immediately, because that
unfortunately, I watched that movie when
I was not an
Adventist yet, or when I still watched
movies.
suggest people watch it. It is a
tremendous distortion. Yes, because the
movie's name was um
Devil's Advocate.
And with Al Pacino and Keanu Reeves.
And Al Pacino portrayed the
the devil.
And he was there in one scene shouting
about this Absentee Landlord.
Now,
actually, what he said and that's the
thing, so it's ringing in my mind still
that that that part of the film, because
you can't get rid of it.
But um
he's actually portraying exactly how the
devil is accusing God. Yes, and uh he
did a good job, but it's a distorted
job.
And if you want to see it from from that
perspective,
then God is indeed an Absentee Landlord.
I mean, why did deism come into
existence?
And remember that
uh even Miller Yes, William Miller. was
a deist for quite a while, and the
entire circle
of people of influence in his time
were basically deists. They were
basically the enlightened ones. Yes,
they were the enlightened ones, and uh
many of the people involved in the
American
uh government and in the Constitution,
they were deists.
And deism
portrays God as the absentee landlord.
Now, why do people think like that?
They think like that because this world
is in such a mess.
Everything is in such a mess.
The landlord's not taking care of it.
He's just leaving it. And this is the
devil's accusation, and in that movie,
actually said, you know, he gets his
hands dirty, he's busy with the
nitty-gritty of this world trying to
sort things out,
but that one, my goodness, he's just the
absentee landlord.
Now,
one thing
negates the absentee landlord picture.
And that's the cross.
Exactly. That shows you exactly how
intimately involved God is. Correct. So,
the cross and the absentee landlord,
they don't gel.
Something is amiss.
But the accusations are real. If
something goes wrong in this world, it's
an act of God. Yeah. Now, if it was an
act of God, then isn't he involved?
Yeah, what a statement. Yeah, exactly.
Okay, then it's then he's involved, but
he's only involved in the negative. Yes.
Not in the positive.
If anything happens that man could not
control, that's God's fault. So, the
devil says, "If you if you're happy,
it's because of him. If you're
miserable, it's because of God."
And it's portrayed in in in everything,
in in every way of thinking.
If somebody dies, then people shout,
"God, why did you do this to me?"
God is the god of the negatives, and the
devil is the god of the positives.
Or so it seems. But then why is the
world in such a mess? Well, because he's
an absentee landlord.
You see the circle? Goes round and
round.
whole time the accusation is back,
it's God's fault. It's God's fault.
Everything is God's fault.
So, I thought it's time that we
just had a look at the concept of the
absentee landlord.
And
let me get my
trusty little clicker
into action.
So, titled Absentee Landlord.
And here are just some thoughts.
The most important lesson that we need
to learn in order to get to heaven is to
understand the root of sin.
Sin is an intruder,
and it needs to be rooted out. It is a
destroyer of relationships,
and therefore contrary to the principle
of love. And the Bible says God is love.
So, sin must be an intruder, right?
Cuz it's contrary to the principle of
love.
The root of all sin is selfishness.
And the root of all goodness is
selflessness
or humility.
Now, those are the aspects that you find
in God. That's it.
Who is portrayed as the villain in all
of these movies and in all occult
writings.
I mean, Blavatsky puts it quite plainly
that God is to blame for everything.
He's the evil one. He is the serpent.
She turns it round, right?
So,
we don't need false humility, but you
need real humility.
So, all relationships operate on one
principle and that principle
is love.
It's interesting how the devil distorts
love. Hollywood Oh, yeah. portrays love
as eros. Mhm. Passion. From where you
get the word erotic from.
So, Hollywood's love is eros. Eros is
not even mentioned in the Bible.
You have phileo. Mhm. From which you get
the word Philadelphia, brotherly love.
And you have agapeo,
which is selfless love,
which the world doesn't even recognize.
The ancient Greeks never even
recognized agapeo. But, it's the highest
form of love
in the Bible.
Yeah. Yeah. And the unrecognizable
absentee
quality
on earth.
So, we need real humility. All
relationships operate on one principle
and that principle is love. It's other
centeredness.
Yes.
Love is a principle and it's not a
feeling.
But, it's not devoid of feeling. Of
course, you have feelings, but the
feelings mustn't be the guide. The
principle must be the guide. Yes, the
sequence must be right. Yes. Yes. It's
It's like the commandments and works.
Yes. You don't have works to get to get
faith. You have faith and out of that
flows your works.
So, God in his wisdom put the brain on
top.
And the mouth second.
Often, the mouth controls
where the head should control. That's
exactly.
And the next one down is the stomach.
And the lower down you go on the body,
the more power they seem to have.
But, it should be the reverse. It should
all be controlled by principle. We all
need a great reset. Yes, we need a great
reset. You see, all relationships are
are built on this aspect of love.
But, sometimes you have to tame the
passion
in order to elevate the principle.
Now, Martin, if you
uh if you Let's use an example.
Someone with patience
working with an untrainable horse.
That when you come into that arena and
you're trying to train this horse that
throws off everyone. Nobody can work
with that horse. And whipping didn't
help. It just made him worse.
And you get this one person, a horse
whisperer.
And this horse becomes tamer and tamer
and tamer.
And eventually, it walks up to the man
or the woman, whoever it is, and puts
the head next to that head. Then, you
have a relationship.
But, the relationship could not exist
before the temperament was tamed.
That's all. Yeah, that's true. If you
get a dog out of
an abused dog out of a pound, a
whimpering little hound with ears
drooping, tails between the legs,
sitting in a corner, shaking with fear.
That's the other opposite, right?
From this high-spirited aggression.
And nothing works with this dog except
patience,
love,
kindness.
Actually, the same remedy.
The same remedy. And eventually,
the ears go up, the tail comes up, comes
closer, learns to trust humanity again.
And before long, he's running around,
bounding around, playing with balls,
happy as a lark, right?
That's how it happens.
So, love is the principle.
And
if love doesn't control the passions
and the feelings,
then the passions and the feelings reign
and the principle disappears. Yeah.
That's a very good explanation on both
sides, like you just mentioned. So,
everything in the spectrum of how we use
our feelings
Yes. has to be get kept into harmony
with love. Then, it will be balanced.
Correct. And you can bring you can bring
this aspect into anything. You can bring
it into worship.
When feeling starts controlling the
worship,
you end up with eventually
such characteristics that thinking
people will be disgusted.
All right?
In Genesis 3:22, we read, "And the Lord
God said, 'Behold, the man is become as
one of us, to know good and evil. And
now,
lest he put forth his hand and take also
of the tree of life and eat and live
forever.'"
So, what he did is he prevented him from
eating from the tree of life and man was
subject to death. Yeah.
But, that didn't mean that he rejected
him. Mhm. Because he gave a promise of
redemption, right?
And we discussed that last time.
So, let's progress from there. But, now
we're going to go to the absentee
landlord.
If he if he
was so concerned about humanity that he
was prepared to sacrifice himself
for their redemption,
then how does that fit in with an
absentee landlord? There must be
something that we're missing, right?
Okay.
So, let's ask some questions.
I know we can spend some time on
questions. I like questions. Yeah.
And people always say, "Why do you ask
stupid questions?" There's no such thing
as a stupid question, right? A question
is a question. Something that bothers
some someone. The only stupid question
is the one never asked.
You're right. Very good, Martin.
So, what does God say
"Man is become like one of us"?
What is it about man that even angels
long to look into?
All right, let's ask some questions.
First question, does Satan hate God?
Yes.
He must, right? He must hate him with
every fiber of his being.
So, every accusation that comes out of
his mouth
will be negative. must be evaluated and
Yeah. Even if it's positive, it must
there might be something in there. There
might be a twist in the tail, right?
All right, so
Satan doesn't operate on the principle
of love. He operates on the principle of
hate.
Yes. Hate is very powerful.
Hate actually runs the world. What are
wars about? That's it.
It's about hate, right? Selfishness and
hate. I think those two
run together. You don't even know that
you hate when you've got selfishness.
Okay.
Uh and even in marriage, Yeah.
love can turn to hate. Mhm.
And hate is very destructive. But, love
is more powerful than hate. Did you know
that? Although, it often seems to be the
underdog.
All right, so we've answered this
question, does Satan hate God? There's
no doubt that he hates him with every
fiber of his being. Why does he hate
him?
Because he's
unselfish. God is unselfish.
And he is selfish and those two spirits
clash.
So, the question is why does he hate
him?
What character trait of God
does he hate? Definitely the
unselfishness. Definitely the
unselfishness of God. But, how can you
be a ruler?
How can you be a powerful ruler of the
entire universe
and not be
absolutely
in control and commandeering everyone to
go and do whatever it is your whim tells
you?
Yeah. You see, that's that's a problem
as well because like we've seen in the
previous
selfishness
is also linked to love. That's the
definition. Mhm. So, and that's why he
hates it because it's not supposed He
doesn't want What is this love? You're
actually a softy.
A pushover when you're full of love.
Why does the world love tyrants? Yeah.
Until they see what tyrany leads to.
Then, all of a sudden, they hate it.
Just for a while.
And then, they choose the next one.
Exactly.
Why is it?
Because they Satan rules the world.
Now if you you watch these, let's say,
in some of these communist countries,
when the ruler comes in and everybody
has to get up and clap like crazy and if
you don't, you probably end up somewhere
in a dungeon, right? At worst at best.
And
this is the kind of power
that people want in a crisis.
Democracy is the final step before
tyranny, they say.
And we're at that point now. Yeah.
Democracy has run its course
and we're getting to the point where
it's so out of control that the only
thing that mankind wants is tyranny.
And they're going to choose it. They're
going to choose it.
And the result will be
devastating.
destruction. Hasn't it been the same
throughout history? That's it. But like
we
history tends to repeat itself.
Absolutely.
All right. So, would you agree, Martin,
that
the devil hates God
because he
hates the unselfish
character trait that God has.
That's for sure.
The humility. Mhm.
The humility.
Now doesn't it say that Moses was the
most humble of men?
Yeah. Yet he was the leader, right?
a pushover. No, he wasn't a pushover,
but he was humble.
All right. So, let's ask the next
question. Does Satan hate enough to
kill? Yes. Has he proved it?
Yes. Did he even kill the son of God?
Yeah. Wasn't that his act his actual
target?
100%. That's what his the whole thing
was about.
Now what a pity for him
that that son of God was God
so that he could rise from the dead.
That must be very disconcerting.
That's why he's so
exceedingly vengeful now.
All right.
So, let's get to the nitty-gritty
question. Why is God an absentee
landlord?
Why did he say it is expedient
for me to go?
So, that the Holy Spirit can come. Mhm.
Can you see the Holy Spirit? No.
No, you can't see the Holy Spirit. Can
you experience him? Yes.
All right. You can experience the
the Holy Spirit.
That's a But where's Jesus?
In heaven.
So, he's an absentee landlord.
Yes, but he's sent a representative.
Okay.
So, let's ask another question. What
happened that necessitated such a
drastic action?
He had to become human.
All right. He had to become human. Well,
he gave up his omnipresence.
Yes.
Because he had to become human to save
the human race. All right. So, that
really must require
tremendous love, right? I mean,
definitely. Okay.
So,
what happened? There was this intruder
in society
which was called sin. Mhm.
And sin needs to be eradicated from the
heart and it needs to be eradicated from
the mind
and sin is based on selfishness. Every
single aspect Why would you want another
God besides you?
Mhm. Because of selfishness, For sure.
Why would you not want to acknowledge
the one true God? Because of
selfishness.
That's it. Because why
would you want to kill or steal or
murder in order to avoid being
associated with him? No. Selfishness.
Okay.
So, the answer is sin entered the
universe.
The next question is who's to blame?
Well, now Satan accuses God, but it's
actually his his fault. It's his Satan's
fault. Yes, he was perfect
from the day that he was created until
iniquity, sin, was found in him.
So, he was created perfect, but that
doesn't exclude the capacity
to sin.
In other words, you must have freedom of
choice in order to be able to sin,
otherwise you'd be a robot. That's it.
And since love is unselfish, you cannot
exclude something. No.
So, as well, love is also not possible
if there's no free choice. So, man has
become like one of us, knowing good and
evil.
God is not evil. No. But being God, he
knows the consequences of evil. It's
almost as if you can say
man now knows selfishness and
unselfishness. All right.
So, now there's a choice to be made.
Humanity has to make a choice
between humility and unselfishness Mhm.
and arrogance and selfishness.
Yeah.
There was actually selfishness that Eve
portrayed.
Because Satan said, "No, you will
God does not want you to be like him.
You can be like him." So, she wanted to
be selfish and She wanted to be like
him. She wanted to have a position that
was not assigned to her.
To know everything. Yes. So, who's to
blame? According to the scriptures,
Satan is to blame. According to Satan,
God is to blame.
Because he made a law. Why should holy
beings such as himself be subject to a
law?
Sin is the transgression of the law.
Okay.
Now, we know who, according to the
scripture, is to blame.
But the next question is who gets the
blame? God. God gets the blame. Normally
it's like that.
In in in anything
that the one that's trying to do the
best and good and
he's always blamed for everything. Yes,
he's try always being blamed.
And the peacekeeper Mhm.
often becomes the worst enemy, right?
If you try and mediate in a marriage,
for example,
you become the enemy. That's it. I've
experienced it a few times in my life.
You try and sort things out and try and
be
uh impartial as possible, but very soon
you become the enemy.
So, it's a very, very thankless job.
All right. The next question then, after
we have ascertained who is to blame, ask
ourselves the question,
why does he get the blame? Why does God
get the blame? Once again, it's
selfishness. Because they don't want the
love or the unselfishness
that he gives. All right. Were you
created
to be a groveling admirer? No.
Exactly, no.
Or were you re created for relationship?
That's it. And then through that
experience the wonderful
blessings that unselfishness and love
gives. Now, Martin, what must it be like
to be created for relationship
with God?
Uh it depends on who God is and what God
is.
Yeah.
As to whether you would even want a
relationship, right?
So, you can see it. Does he want if he
if you can understand that he wants the
best for you.
So, then you will see that he is
uh say, for instance, the 10
Commandments is not there to keep you
from having joy in life. It's actually
there to give you joy in life. Okay.
Depends what side of the equation you
are on, right? Yes. So, Martin, if you
are dealing with someone who's totally
unselfish, who's the beneficiary? You.
Okay. And if you are dealing with
someone who's totally selfish, who's the
beneficiary? You. Huh? Okay.
All right.
So, why does he get the blame?
Well,
because he created in the first place.
Yeah.
Don't the children say, "I didn't ask to
be here?"
Oh, yes.
Right?
Now, why do they ask that question? And
when do they ask that question? When?
So, normally they in trouble. Ah.
When they have transgressed.
Yes.
When they have transgressed, they say,
"I didn't ask to be here." I didn't ask
to be here. Or when they asked to do
something like wash the dishes or help
in the house or whatever. "I didn't ask
to be here. You're supposed to be my
slave."
No, we're supposed to be a community.
We're supposed to work together. "No, I
didn't ask to be here."
All right. So, the blame game,
does the blame game come from the
transgressor
or does it come from the creator? No,
the transgressor.
We're getting somewhere, Martin. Yeah,
you can what
why this whole
great controversy is
going on. All right. So, we're living in
a great blame game, are we not? Oh.
I always smile when I read that portion
of Genesis.
Where
Adam and Eve transgressed. No one is
taking responsibility. They're just
blaming the other. Yeah, it's
All the time.
All right. Now, why does he get the
blame? It's because he permitted it.
He should have been a tyrant.
Then we wouldn't have had this nonsense.
Exactly. True.
It's like people like you just mentioned
earlier, they want a dictator. Yes.
They scream against him, but then like
you said, just the next election or the
next one,
we want him back. We want him back.
Okay.
All right. So, we've run through a a
whole host of questions. And the
question is still
why is God an absentee landlord? What
does he achieve by being an absentee
landlord?
He's definitely not doing it because of
indifference. No. And also not of
uncaringness.
Because the cross negates that.
Because that's a problem. People say,
"Okay, like you mentioned, look at the
what's going on.
How can a loving God let this happen?"
Okay.
So, let's try and dwell upon the
question, why did he
permit it?
Why did he permit it?
Okay. Let's see if this makes any sense.
Because he hates sin more than the
consequences.
He was prepared to bear the consequences
himself.
Does that make sense?
It makes sense.
Because it's the only way that he can
show that it's true.
He can set it right. Okay. The only way
because otherwise
all the other accusations will be true.
Okay. So, can we safely say and the
Bible says it quite clearly that God
hates sin. Yes.
So, if he hates sin
then why did he permit it?
Because obviously sin was going to have
consequences. Yes. Right?
But he permitted it anyway.
Yeah, he had to.
Because the the the alternative was to
create you a robot.
Yeah. And then you don't have love. No.
So, he had to permit it because
only if there is the choice to sin,
there can be love. Okay.
That's actually a very
scary thought.
Scary thought. Okay.
So, he had to permit it
or else he's not a god of love.
He could have chosen not to create it.
But then you don't have a relationship.
Yeah.
Then it's not worth nothing.
So, he was prepared to bear the
consequences himself.
So, what does that tell you about his
longing for relationship?
Yeah. That's why he actually created I'm
sure. All right. So, the longing for
relationship must be so great that he
was prepared to die for it.
That's quite a thought there.
The longing for relationship was so
great
that he was prepared to die for it.
Now, if you if your longing for
relationship is so great that you are
prepared to die for it
why would you be an absentee landlord?
If you long for a relationship with a
woman
that you love
why would you by choice be an absentee
landlord?
Does that make sense? Not a lot. No.
Okay. We're running through some
thoughts here, but
I hope the people will understand what
we're trying to get at.
Well, if you take it like this
that will show you if she really loves
you.
If you have this
distance. Okay. For if she can continue
keeping your love of your life, if she
keeps faithful to you even though you're
absent from her. All right. Let's let's
take a situation of war.
And
you are taken away on a war mission.
You enter into No.
You climb on board of that big vessel
and you wave goodbye
with many many tears
and off you sail
perhaps to be gone for a number of
years.
That surely puts a test test to a
relationship, doesn't it?
If it's still there when you come back,
you can you can safely tie that knot
forever. So, I think there's very much
method in what he's doing.
Okay.
All right.
So, what were the consequences?
They were pain
suffering
and death.
Now
if he left us to those
then he would be an absentee landlord.
But if he embraced them himself
is he then an absentee landlord?
Not at all.
He might be gone
but he's not absent.
All right. If you are on that military
expedition, if you've been sent away to
the army
where's your heart?
On the other side of the ocean. On the
other side of the ocean.
And
like you said, he he came and he
actually
paid all of this himself.
Well, when he became absentee, when he
ascended to heaven he sent a
representative of himself
to be a still.
Correct. To work with hearts and minds.
Hearts and minds. So, in actual fact
through his representative, he's not
absentee.
Okay. Let's ask another question. We've
now concluded that he hates sin.
Does that mean
that he hates the sinner? So, does he
hate the sinner? No.
No.
We tend to do that. Yeah. Oh, yes.
Somebody that transgresses against you,
you tend to hate the person rather than
the deed. In fact, you hate the person
more than the deed.
You really want to sort that person out.
Don't you?
Okay. That's a lesson. What does God
want to do to that person?
to save the sinner. He wants to redeem
him.
All right.
So, let's ask the other question. Do we
hate the sinner?
Unfortunately, this asks do we, not
should we. So, do we? Yes. Should we
hate the sinner?
Okay.
All right, Martin. So, are there lessons
to be learned?
Yes.
Now
how much
do we actually hate the sinner? Do we
hate the sinner enough to kill him or
her?
Actually, yes.
Otherwise, we wouldn't have the
situations on earth, right? We wouldn't
have wars.
We wouldn't have anything. You know, you
can put this literal and you can put it
spiritual.
Because do we
hate the sinner enough not to even
evangelize him or talk to him and
thereby
in effect kill him.
Now, when Paul was persecuting the
Christians
and in vision
the representative
of God on earth, the human
representative was told
Paul is praying. He says, "Lord, do you
not know what this man is doing?" No, I
want you to go and anoint him.
And I want you to
take him up into the fold as a brother.
Was even that representative
spluttering? Of course. But if you put
yourself in that one if there's somebody
going out there that's constantly and
you know he is
the
top ranked Okay, this one was now
spiritual one, but he's the top ranked
say
atheist that's getting rid of people.
And you have to go and anoint him.
A very tough thing to do.
All right. So, we actually hate sinners
enough to kill them.
Or if someone transgressed against you
and uh
when it comes to some relationships, I
mean, why do we have sayings about
ladies that have been
scorned in a relationship? Hell has no
fury as a woman scorned.
There's a lot of
animosity that comes out.
Okay. Do we transfer the hatred for the
deed to the perpetrator?
Yes.
We do, huh? And that's it. We
the deed falls into the background
eventually. Yes. You just get this
you start building up this whole hate
for that perpetrator. And when you look
at propaganda
let's say war propaganda
don't you
create an atmosphere of hatred for the
other party. That 100% for the for a
total for a people. Yes, for a whole
nation.
How crazy is that? I mean, just take
this for instance. You have brothers in
the faith in that country as well.
Yes. As well as in this country.
told to go and kill them all. And then
huh? It It doesn't even make sense.
How can you partake in this?
Okay, so this is the mess that we are
in. And we're still trying to answer the
question.
Why is he an absentee landlord?
Right?
So, we're approaching it but
obliquely. We're coming from the side of
asking questions.
Cuz basically what we need to do in this
life is we need to understand the
character
and the mindset of God.
Because if we don't
we will end up like the devil hating
him.
That's it. And we have to be of one mind
with him so that we can be of one accord
and one mind together. You're absolutely
right.
So, are we inclined to transfer the
hatred to the one who permitted it?
That's
That's a bit more complicated.
that's exactly what happens. Because now
you That's what happens. The perpetrator
you hate him actually now at the and
more than what he did. And then you
start hating
obviously God for permitting it. All
right, let's say you have
uh parents. One is abusive. The other
one is submissive.
And the child suffers at the hands of
the abuser.
The child can actually start hating the
other parent who who permitted it
without saying anything. Yeah.
So, hatred doesn't have to necessarily
only be towards the perpetrator.
It can actually be to
the one who permitted it. And sometimes
the hatred towards the one who permitted
it can be even greater. It was, yeah.
Because you feel abandoned. You feel a
sense of abandonment.
Abandonment. Isn't that an absentee
landlord? Yeah.
Yeah. So, is it possible that when life
throws you a curveball
that you can become
full of animosity
to the one who permitted it?
It is That's most of the time that what
happens.
All right. So, if something happens in
your life, somebody dies
somebody's killed in a car accident
your fury and your anger and your
sadness is often directed towards
someone.
You have to get rid of it somewhere. You
have to unload it.
That's it. So, who you going to unload
it on? Normally the one that you
actually supposed to run to.
Okay, so you start hating the one who
can who's the only one who can comfort
you.
The world is in a mess, Martin.
The world is in a mess.
Is God wise?
All wise.
All right, the Bible says so.
Is his wisdom being seriously challenged
here?
Definitely.
Okay.
So, let's ask the question then, do we
play the blame game?
That's for sure.
Nobody will It It started with the blame
game. You said it right from the
beginning. The woman you gave me. That's
The serpent you created. Why'd you
create that stupid serpent? It's your
fault. Exactly. The whole time it's his
fault. Whatever happens, it's his fault.
And So, when when Adam said the woman
you gave me
who's the accusation against? God. Not
against the woman.
No.
God. It's against God. The serpent you
created. Who's the accusation God again?
It's never It's not even the serpent's
fault or anything. It's God's fault. No,
it's never your fault.
No.
That's blame game that you just asked. I
I You know how much
better everything will start going if
just everybody start taking
responsibility
without blame just blaming. Okay.
All right. Now, if you had a referee who
could sort all of this out and keep
everything under perfect control all the
time
wouldn't it be better?
So, don't we need a tyrant, Martin?
Yeah.
That we need a strong man who will sort
these things out.
Exactly.
Uh is the world looking for one? Yes.
The world is looking for one and they
want to blame someone. And will they get
him? Yes.
Okay. But who will he blame? He also has
someone to blame. He will blame God
again. God. He'll blame God.
All right, so we've come
almost full circle.
So, the absentee landlord
is actually not unrepresented.
He is represented by his
representatives.
Mhm.
So, he's actually
given the gift of the Holy Spirit.
And he has through the Holy Spirit
transformed people so as to represent
him.
So, he's not unrepresented. Mhm. He's
just not physically here.
Yeah.
But he's not unrepresented.
Okay.
And these representatives are actually
fellow sufferers whom he calls friends.
Is that right?
That's it. So, he's
You're not going through this alone.
Okay. Now
why would he choose to be represented
by representatives
rather than present himself?
Well, he did.
Yes, you're right.
He actually did, but for a very short
time.
Yeah.
Did they like it?
No.
No, they hated it. All right, why did
they hate it? B- I don't know because
they didn't want him here. Why did they
not want him here? Because Because he
was unselfish and they were selfish.
the same thing that's
happened in heaven
actually
re-happened on Earth. Okay. Now, let's
say he came again in the form of a
humble servant to humanity.
What would they do? The same. They're
going to do exactly the same.
going to do the same. So, had he been
here constantly, he would have been
sacrificed how many times over by now?
They would have They constantly. But if
he came
as a tyrant
they would have loved him.
This is a very
serious issue, Martin.
I mean, that's what they actually
thought he was going to. Even his
disciples, they wanted him to take the
throne and get rid of the you know
Okay, so his representatives
are they suffering? Yes.
His representatives are suffering. Isn't
he then a selfish God who says, "All
right, I'm not going to suffer. You can
suffer in my stead." Well, actually no.
They just showing that he's worthy.
Because the same that they go through is
what people are doing to him. All right,
I think we're getting somewhere now.
So, Martin
if he uses the representatives
who becomes fellow sufferers
they can only become fellow sufferers if
they understand the mindset of God
because only if they understand the
mindset of God will they want to be
partakers with him in his suffering.
That's it. And
exactly. Because you won't want to
suffer if it's not for a good cause.
Okay. So, in other words, you must be
convinced that the lap
that the absentee landlord
in your personal experience is actually
not absent but very much involved.
Yes. And actually that everything he
stands for is worthy. Is what you also
then want to stand All right, but if you
are standing outside of this
relationship
can you see it?
No.
No. All you see is an absentee landlord.
That's it. Because you don't see the
presence of the landlord in the
suffering
and activities of his representative.
Okay. I think it's
So, is he absent?
No.
Not at all. Yeah, it's
it's because those that are in a
relationship with him, they understand
his character. They start understanding
what it means when he's unselfish.
Okay.
John 14:7 says, "If you had known me
you should have known my father also.
And from henceforth you know him and
have seen him."
Have they actually seen him?
Not physically, no. They saw his
representative. That's it.
But he says when you saw him, you saw
the father. Okay. So
if you want to know Jesus
should you be able to recognize him in
his representatives?
Yes.
Mhm. Do we do a good job at that?
No.
Martin
You're very pessimistic. What's wrong
with you?
God said, "If he If he returns, will he
find faith?" And by the way, this is a
very serious subject. Why are we
laughing all the time?
Cuz we're also guilty.
Okay.
All right. John 15:15
"Henceforth, I call you not servants.
For the servant knoweth not what his
lord doeth.
But I have called you friends.
For all things that I have heard of my
father, I have made known unto you."
Do we know the origin of sin? Yes.
Do we understand its consequences? Do we
feel it in our own skins?
We can see it all around us.
Okay.
So, if you rightly represent him,
then is he absent? No.
No, huh?
Now, Martin, doesn't he say
that if you overcome,
you will sit with him in his throne?
In other words, your mindset will be
such that he can safely rule together
with you.
Now, would a tyrant like that?
No.
Nobody sits on his throne next to him.
Huh?
The Führer,
would he Would he like someone to,
you know, sit right not only next to
him, that would might still be
tolerable,
but to sit in him in his throne, to be
part and parcel of every decision? Would
he like that? No, then he's no longer a
tyrant.
Tells you something about the character
of God, right?
Okay. So, in order to represent him, we
must know him.
So, how, Martin, do we get to know him?
By having a relationship. By start And
the only way to have that is for
from what he's left us. And that is his
word.
That's very good.
Go Let's have a look how we get to know
him. There are a few ways in which we
can get to know him so that we may
represent him. And if he is perfectly
represented,
then he's not absent.
We can get to know him through prayer.
When self is woven into our labors,
then the truth we bear to others does
not sanctify,
refine, and ennoble our own hearts.
It will not testify that we are fit
vessels for the master's use.
It is only through fervent prayer
that we may hold sweet fellowship with
Jesus.
Fellowship, is that absent to you, or is
that present?
Definitely present. Okay.
And through this blessed communion, the
words and the spirit are made fragrant
with the spirit of Christ.
There is not a heart that will not bear
watching.
Jesus, the precious savior, enjoined
watchfulness.
The oversight of self must not be
relaxed for a moment. The heart must be
kept with diligence,
for out of it are the issues of life.
Watch and discipline the thoughts
that you may not sin with your lips.
Martin, the representative must have the
same mindset towards sin as the one you
are representing.
Yeah, correct. Otherwise, it's futile.
You must hate sin.
You must also have the same mindset
towards the sinner, or else he won't
represent him.
He must also have the same character,
or else he cannot be a good
representative.
So, you better be in communion with him,
and that you do through fervent prayer.
You hold fellowship with him. And
you have to discipline your thoughts
so that you may not sin with your lips.
Once again, it's that sequence.
Okay. Mind
first over the rest. First, it starts
here and then goes down, not the other
way around. Okay. The second way we have
fellowship with Jesus is through the
word.
Let us run with endurance the race that
is set before us, looking unto Jesus,
the author and finisher of our faith.
No man, woman, or youth can attain to
Christian perfection and neglect the
study of the word of God.
By careful and closely searching his
word, we shall obey the injunctions of
Christ. "Search the scriptures, for in
them you think you have eternal life,
and they are they which testify of me."
This search enables the student to
closely observe the divine model,
for they testify of Christ. The pattern
must be inspected often and closely
in order to imitate it.
So, Martin, if he were present, would we
learn any of these things, or would we
just We won't need to study it in the
word anymore. And he will be there, so
He will be there. Do we have to exercise
our own uh initiatives and judgments as
well when he's there, or could we leave
it all up to him? Then you could leave
it all up to him. Yeah, you could do it
all, and you could take a backseat and
watch the show, right?
Yes. Can you do it this way?
Nope.
You have to partake. So, what's better
for you?
That's why he said.
What's What's better for you?
It's better for you that he's not He's
He's got a representative here. Okay.
But, Martin, one day it will be over,
and he will actually be there.
Is that then Isn't it better if he never
is there?
No.
No, because you have to have eventually
the reward for what you've tried to
represent.
Ah, in other words, if you have
developed the character,
then it's no longer necessary that he be
absent to you.
Exactly.
Then he can be fellowship.
Okay. So, as long as sin reigns,
it's better that he be an absentee.
Yeah.
And as soon as sin is overcome,
completely eradicated, it's no longer
necessary to be an absentee.
Does that make sense?
It makes a lot of sense, actually, now.
Yes.
So, the accusation of the devil in that
movie
is it true or is it false?
It's totally false.
He's a liar.
From the beginning.
He's always been a liar.
All right. The third way
that you gain this is by experience.
That's why I mentioned my wife's book,
too.
Not because of any selfish motive or
tapping on the shoulder, but just to
show
how God worked. And how, if through
experience,
you gain the a better knowledge A better
knowledge and understanding, because you
you wrestle with him, and you you try to
understand. And one is very inclined to
have all the accusations that come out
of the devil's mouth.
But eventually, once you start
understanding the issue,
you say, "Woe is me, I am undone. I'm a
man of unclean lips living amongst the
people of unclean lips."
And then he says, "Who shall I send?"
And I say, "Okay, send me."
Here I am. Here I am.
In actual experience, Christ has
overcome the world. And how great is his
love to us when he invites us
to come to him in all our afflictions,
the stresses, heartaches, perplexities,
with the assurance that he will help us.
He will bring health and brightness into
our lives. If we place our hand in the
hand of Jesus Christ, he will place our
feet on solid rock.
A better foundation than we ever had
before. He will make us more strong in
his strength, and he will work with all
our efforts. Then,
when our own souls have experienced his
healing touch, we are brought into close
fellowship with Jesus.
And we will be laborers together with
God, not only to restoring the erring,
to repair broken hearts and souls, but
to impart courage and faith and
confidence.
This is the work of God's laborers,
to bring to Jesus souls who have gone
away from his direct teachings,
and have apparently gone to pieces on
the rocks and reefs of sin.
These broken lives, which have been
apparently hopeless,
he promises to make whole.
So, Martin,
this is training
of the highest order.
In
real life.
So, you have to learn to pray.
Mhm.
And you don't need prayer if he's not an
absentee. No.
Cuz there's that hymn,
"Sweet hour of prayer, farewell,
farewell,
sweet hour of prayer." You don't need it
anymore, right?
So, you need prayer. Yeah.
Uh for prayer, you need faith. That's
it.
Because who are you going to pray to?
Mhm. And why are you going to pray to
someone?
And you need to knowledge of the word,
otherwise you're going to despair.
And then you need an experience. And you
can only have all three of those Yeah.
if he's an absentee landlord. Yeah.
Without being an absentee landlord,
because you have fellowship.
Yeah. So,
what is the basis of everything?
Fellowship.
That's it.
You mean to tell me, Martin, God wants
fellowship with us sinners?
How much?
So much that he actually came and died
for it.
That's a pretty deep thought, right?
That's a pretty deep thought.
All right, let's read another quote. "If
the majesty of heaven could do so much
to evidence his love for man,
what ought ought not men to be willing
to do for each other to help one another
up out of the pit of darkness and
suffering?"
Martin, this is the test. Are you going
to sit and whine? Are you going to
accuse constantly? Are you going to be
fault finding constantly? Or are you
prepared to get your hands dirty?
Get your hands dirty and do what he
would do. Okay. What if it costs you
your life? Then so it so be it. It cost
his life. Okay.
Said Christ, "Love one another as I have
loved you, not with a greater love,
for greater love has no man than this,
that a man lay down his life for his
friends. Our love is frequently selfish,
for we confine it to prescribed limits.
When we come into close union and
fellowship with Jesus Christ, our love
and sympathy and our works of
benevolence will reach down deeper and
will widen and strengthen with exercise.
The love and interest of Christ's
followers must be as broad as the world.
And those who live merely for me and
mine will fail of heaven."
Mhm.
Martin, there are religions
which are so self-centered.
You know, that there is no love for the
world.
No love for the
Hollywood's
um motto is believe in yourself.
Follow your heart.
That's selfish. That's absolute
selfishness.
It's all based on the principles of
Luciferian thinking.
It's based on aprons, That's it.
which are fig leaves.
And you know, actually, and we will talk
about this also sometime, sports is also
built on selfishness. Yes, we need to
talk about sport. Well, well, we need to
make some more enemies.
And music.
All right, let's have a look how this
works in real life. You have the testing
of Job.
"For those who love God, those who are
the called according to his purpose,
Romans 8:28, Bible biography has a yet
higher lesson
of the ministry of sorrow.
You are my witnesses, says the Lord,
that I am God.
Witnesses that he is good and that
goodness is supreme. We are made a
theater unto the world both to angels
and to men, 1 Corinthians 4:9.
So, the presence of God
is enacted
in his followers.
Yeah.
So, he's not an absentee landlord. We
come back to that all the time.
But in the crucible of the world, you
learn to understand
what the issue is
in the great controversy.
And that's why your wife wrote the book,
because in the crucible, you've been to
actually understand
being the representative.
Okay. And Martin, is anybody excluded
from the crucible? No.
Why do they all shout like crazy when
they're in the crucible? Because you
don't understand fully why you are
there. Did Job's friends understand?
No.
No, they played the blame game.
Who was to blame?
Yeah, what did you do? Who is this? What
Listen.
Whose fault was it they asked Jesus?
Was it his fault or his parents' fault
that he was born blind?
Somebody has to get the blame.
Unselfishness,
the principle of God's kingdom is the
principle that Satan hates. Didn't we
speak about that? That's it.
Its very existence he denies. From the
beginning of the great controversy, he
has endeavored to prove God's principles
of action to be selfish.
When I was an atheist, I was
absolutely convinced that God is 100%
selfish.
And therefore I denied his very
existence.
He wants you to grovel in front of him,
fall on your knees, worship him from
morning till night,
and that's it.
And that is a useless form of worship.
Mhm. You actually worship and fall on
him because
sacrifice and offering he doesn't
require.
The sacrifices of a contrite heart, that
is what he seeks. He wants you to have
this unselfish character because only in
an unselfish character environment can
love thrive.
You have to have the right manure to
make the plant grow.
That's how That's how it is. And once
again, if you misunderstand this, you'll
see this as wimpfulness. I don't know if
that's even a word, but Well, make it
up. It's a pretty good word.
wimp if you don't want to
stand up and be a man, man. What Okay.
That's That's how you thought, because
everybody that goes on his knees in
front of somebody is a wimp. "All right,
so to disprove Satan's claim is the work
of Christ and of all who bear his name."
That's the crux of the matter.
"And if you want to disprove Satan's
claim, you have to in this world live
the life that Christ lived."
You have to.
And you will be accused.
You will, because then you are his
representative.
Then you are forming part of
helping him not being absentee.
"It was to give in his own life an
illustration of unselfishness that Jesus
came in the form of humanity.
And all who accept this principle are to
be workers together with him in
demonstrating it in practical life. This
is why God in his wisdom chose to be the
so-called
absentee landlord.
The absenteeism
of God
is a stroke of brilliance.
Now, if he were a tyrant,
it would be a sign of weakness.
That's it.
But if he is unselfish, it's a stroke of
genius.
Yes.
And that's That's the bottom line.
We can actually stop here.
now.
"To choose the right because it is
right, to stand for truth at the cost of
suffering and sacrifice.
This is the heritage of the servants of
the Lord.
And their righteousness is of me, says
the Lord, Isaiah 54:17.
Martin, there it stands in the
scriptures." That makes me think of that
he will be so settled in the truth as
not to be moved.
So, what is truth? He's the truth. You
must understand his character.
All of these questions that are
constantly bombarding humanity's minds
have to be answered. Mhm.
We have to answer them.
That's it. But you can.
You can, yes. You just have to
you're going to suffer when you do it.
That's it. You
The place where you get the answers,
people don't like. No.
"So, very early in the history of the
world is given the life record of one of
whom this controversy of Satan was
waged.
Of Job, the patriarch of Uz,
the testimony of the search of hearts
was, 'There is none like him in the
earth, a perfect and upright man, one
that feareth God and escheweth evil.'
Against this man Satan brought scornful
charge.
'Does Job fear God for naught?
Hast thou not made a hedge about him and
about his house and about all that he
has on every side? Put forth thine hand
now and touch all that he has, touch his
bone and his flesh and he will curse
thee to thy face.
The Lord said unto Satan, "All that he
has is in thy power. Behold, he is in
thine hand, but save his life."
So, was he proved? Yes, definitely.
So, did it show that he was not base
metal, but a precious jewel? So, we've
actually got the same, I'm sure, same
accusation from Satan for all of us.
We're all Job. Yeah.
Job is a type. We're all Job. And we can
either come out like Job, "Even if he
slay me, yet will I trust him." Or his
wife,
"Curse God and die."
Die. Yeah.
That's the choice. It's a choice. We all
have to make that choice. And many, I'm
afraid, will make the choice, "Curse God
and die."
Thus permitted, Satan swept away all
that Job possessed. Flocks and herds,
men servants and maidens, sons and
daughters. And he smote Job with sore
boils from the sole of his foot unto his
crown.
Still another element of bitterness was
added to his cup, his friends.
Seeing in adversity but the retribution
of sin, pressed on his bruised and
burdened spirit their accusations of
wrongdoing.
That's why my wife wrote the book.
Mhm.
Because people were looking at sometimes
in some trouble that you were going
through and they had the same
accusations as Job's friends. And you
try and stand up for
for God and you get blasted off
the kingdom. Just get up. Just say a
simple verse. In the beginning God
created
then the entire academic world comes
down on you like a ton of bricks.
Tries to squash you like a maggot.
Mhm.
Say, "Cheese is not fit to be introduced
into the human stomach." What happens to
you, Martin?
Say that at the potluck.
Say that at the potluck. What happens?
"That was for that time."
"This woman is not a prophet."
Doesn't matter what you say. You also
get those friends then.
There are lots of them around. Lots of
them.
So, Martin, seemingly forsaken of heaven
and earth, yet holding fast his faith in
God and his consciousness of integrity,
in anguish and perplexity he cried,
"My soul is weary of my life. Oh, that
thou wouldst hide me in the grave, that
thou wouldst keep me secret until thy
wrath be past."
Didn't Jeremiah say the same thing?
Yes.
I've said it many times.
Uh-huh. Can we
Can I just
Can everything just happen? Just leave
me alone for a while.
Where haven't we said that in the in a
a few times in the past? Absolutely,
we've said that.
so distant past.
Yeah, sometimes one just wants to
despair, right?
Where's the landlord?
I can't handle this.
That they would appoint me a set time
and remember me. Behold, I cry out of
wrong, but I'm not heard. I cry for
help, but there is no judgment. He has
stripped me of my glory and taken the
crown from my head. My kinsfolk have
failed.
And my familiar friends have forgotten
me. They whom I loved are turned against
me. Have pity upon me. Have pity upon
me, oh ye my friends,
for the hand of God has touched me. Oh,
that I knew where I might find him,
that I might come even to his seat.
Is he accusing God almost of being an
absentee landlord? Yes, he is. But he's
not wailing to God, you know. He's He's
wailing to the friends that God is
absent. All right. So, he didn't give up
on God.
No.
But the situation is just overwhelming.
We'll be experiencing it.
for sure. It's a promise.
It's for sure. Okay.
Behold, I go forward, but he is not
there and backwards, but I cannot
perceive him. Where is he? Is it
absentee landlord? When I need him most,
he is not there.
So, Martin, his reactions
and his statements that he made,
were they right?
Well, it depends on how we see it.
He's right and wrong. If you really
looked for God, he would find him. But
in that circumstance, yes, he's right.
It's All right. So, his accusation No,
his accusers were actually the ones that
were wrong and God reprimanded them.
God
did not leave him in that situation. In
fact, God was more present in that
situation than in any other. And that's
what we have to learn. That's exactly.
And Martin, in the times that we are
living in now, we will we will have to
learn that.
You see,
that's the thing. There's a There's
Let's say smoke in front and God is
behind it. But Satan is push is blowing
the smoke. Now we see through a glass
darkly.
That's
So, we have to realize this dark glass,
this smoke, is not from God. He's there.
We just have to get through this. All
right, Martin, why are we doing this in
the first place? Why are we having these
discussions?
Uh because this is preparation for the
final conflict.
Exactly. So, yeah, we're sitting here
and grinning and smiling and because we
realize we're sitting in the same boat.
Yes, that's what makes it That's what
makes it so familiar that you can
actually smile about it.
it. So, when you read this, then I start
realizing, okay,
now I maybe I must
work a little bit on some things in
inside. So, this is what it's supposed
to to do to to the to everybody.
Preparation for the final crisis.
Okay?
So, he's looking for him and he can't
find him. On the left hand, where does
work, but I cannot behold him. He hideth
himself on the right hand and I cannot
see him. He knoweth the way that I take.
When he has tried me,
I shall come forth as gold.
Though he slay me, yet will I trust him.
Did he understand?
Yes. Yeah. Yes, he understood it. And
what was he What did he realize that he
was being tried?
Yeah.
He realized, okay, wait. He's not an
absentee landlord.
No. He must be right here because he's
trying me in the fire.
I know that my redeemer liveth.
And that he shall stand up at the last
upon the earth. And after my skin has
been destroyed, this shall be even from
my flesh shall I see God, whom I shall
see for myself and my eyes shall behold
and not as a stranger. Does he have the
hope of the second coming?
Yes. Wow, beautiful is that, huh? Yes,
he has it. Exactly. He's not hoping for
that right there.
He's hoping for the second coming.
Correct.
So, according to his faith, so was it
unto Job. When he has tried me, he said,
"I shall come forth as gold."
So, this is the whole issue.
If you want to be in the school,
then you have to go through the process.
And actually, we all have to want to be
in the school. And you have to be a
representative of the character of God.
Because Satan accused him of having a a
false reason for following God. You know
what? You were mentioning something
earlier and I was just thinking now,
this coming forth as gold.
It's never easy to come forth as gold.
No. It's the whole time a crucible. It's
a purifying thing.
So, and people don't like that.
And we cannot exclude ourselves.
No, no. We also scream like
like suckling pigs. But I think the main
difference is we have to want to.
Then you can take it. But if you want to
be again holding unto certain things,
that's when it's becoming very
difficult.
That's when it becomes difficult.
But then it said, "So, it came to pass.
By his patient endurance, he vindicated
his own character
and thus the character of him whose
representative he was." So, what are we
going to do when all of these things
happen to us and when this time of
trouble comes upon us?
Whose representative are we going to be?
Christ.
Are we going to shout, "Absentee
landlord? No. Why did you not prevent
this?" That's when we have to study his
character. So, the Lord turned the
captivity of Job. Also, the Lord gave
Job twice as much as he had before. So,
the Lord blessed the latter end of Job
more than the beginning. Now, the
blessing that we are awaiting is not a
temporal blessing. It's a heavenly
blessing. Eternal one.
And this is where we have to go.
So, on the record of those who through
self-abnegation
have entered into the fellowship of
Christ's sufferings
stand one on the Old Testament and one
in the new, the names of Jonathan
and of John the Baptist. And Martin,
it struck me that she should use those
two names, particularly Jonathan.
Jonathan, by birth heir to the throne,
yet knowing himself set aside by the
divine decree,
to his rival, the most tender and
faithful of his friends, shielding
David's life at the peril of his own,
steadfast at his father's side through
the dark days of his declining power,
and at his side falling at the last. The
name of Jonathan is treasured in heaven.
And it stands on earth a witness to the
existence and power of unselfish
love.
That's amazing, huh? Yeah.
Amazing.
John the Baptist, you know, is very
similar.
He's the one who said, "He must increase
and I must decrease."
So, John the the Baptist, at his
appearance as the Messiah's herald,
stirred the nation.
From the place to place his steps were
followed by vast throngs of people of
every rank and station.
But when the one came to whom he had
borne witness, all was changed. The
crowds followed Jesus.
And John's work seemed fast closing.
Yet there was no wavering of his faith.
He must increase, he said, "But I must
decrease." John 3:30.
Time passed, and the kingdom which John
had confidently expected was not
established.
In Herod's dungeon, cut off from the
life-giving air and the desert freedom,
he waited and watched.
There was no display of arms, no rending
of prison doors,
but the healing of the sick, the
preaching of the gospel, the uplifting
of men's souls testified to Christ's
mission.
Alone in the dungeon, seeing whether his
path, like his master's, tended,
John accepted the trust.
Fellowship with Christ in sacrifice.
That's it. So, he
was
experiencing
this absenteeism.
But they had fellowship in the
absenteeism.
in the end. He third first had all of
this, and he was
because nothing happened. And he had all
these questions, and he sent his
disciples out to ask,
"Are you the one, or do we wait for
another?"
And then
he felt this fellowship. Yes.
Heaven's messengers attended him to the
grave. The intelligences of the
universe, fallen and unfallen, witnessed
his vindication of unselfish service.
Qualified him for heaven.
Unselfish. Now,
with that leaves the question, what
about us, Martin?
Hm? What about us?
In all the generations that have passed
since then, suffering souls have been
sustained by the testimony of John's
life.
In the dungeon, on the scaffold, in the
flames, men and women through centuries
of darkness have been strengthened by
the memory of him of whom Christ
declared,
"Among them that are born of women,
there has not risen a greater."
And what shall I more say?
For the time would fail me to tell of
Gideon and of Barak and of Samson and of
Jephthah.
You know, Martin, when I read those
names, I wonder, why are they included
in the Hall of Fame? They made so many
mistakes, these people. But that's how
God works. It
it's about rectifying the mistake.
What's it uh
seven times you fall, but just get up
again? And Samuel and the prophets.
Samuel was an excellent example.
Who through faith subdued kingdoms,
wrought righteousness, obtained
promises, stopped the mouths of lions,
quenched the violence of fire,
escaped the edge of the sword, out of
weakness were made strong, waxed valiant
in fight, turned to flight the armies of
the aliens.
Women received their dead raised to life
again. Others were tortured, not
accepting deliverance,
that they might obtain a better
resurrection. And others had trial of
cruel mockings and scourging.
Yea, moreover, of bonds and
imprisonment, they were stoned, they
were sawn asunder, they were tempted,
they were slain with a sword. They
wandered about in sheepskins and
goatskins, being destitute, afflicted,
tormented,
of whom the world was not worthy. They
wandered in deserts and in mountains and
in dens and in caves of the earth. And
these all,
having obtained a good report through
faith, received not the promise.
God having provided some better thing
for us,
that they without us should not be made
perfect. What a beautiful verse. Yeah, I
know. Wow. Is he an absentee landlord?
No. No. Did Samson know it? Yes. Did he
then John the Baptist realize
Do you know it? I'm busy doing it. All
right. We're learning. He's not an
absentee landlord. We have to represent
him.
And the world has to see it, and the
world has to understand it.
And very soon, the conflict will come to
a head.
And may God grant us wisdom. We haven't
completed the study.
It's too long for one session, so let's
continue in another episode and see if
we can add some
some thoughts to this
very intriguing subject, the absentee
landlord. Shall we pray? Please.
Heavenly Father,
thank you that you are not an absentee
landlord, even though you are an
absentee landlord.
But in those that you have chosen to
represent you,
in the crucibles of this world,
you have placed a record and a presence
of yourself,
which will echo and re-echo through the
ages until we come to that final
conflict.
And if we cling to our hope
and cling to our faith,
we will hear those words one day, "Well
done, good and faithful servant."
Thank you for the promises.
Thank you for your presence in our
lives. Is my prayer in Jesus' name.
Amen.